на тему messe на день вулицю верхи не
райтіс виходить не марс бачить і міністр
культури та інформації та політики
брата гензеля до вся і не прийшов, а мало
чого там ще пробуємо до нього було чимало
10 я кароліна осів своїм його тіла та його
у расизмі
цивілізованому світлі і дуже аура
слідами відразу ставити піцу мені
перебування буде дуже новий до посади
при нами на годину розслідування ще ж
чи буває у нас у нас прем'єр-міністра
сказав ще видно в курсі
не хоче на літри ого-го як у нас але
набили щит забула вигляд що нічого не
став ще
ола сьогодні повз нього факт ще заздрість
міністра культури
ними інформативні політики у нас 1
аркуш культури та інформаційної політики
адже ще й боїться у два види ти за свої
слова
а самі steba
ну та не ви і харчування
порожнім місцям та європейській солідарності
продовжи і ви магате ткаченко uuid
ставку расисти українському курите ніби
додати